Isis or levers now actually had stuff
coming in from a heinonline oh one is
real champion by max D squadron 22 SAS
don't worry about me let's get it on and
I've been on the frontline with the men
so you were the prison yes and women
risking their lives in a bloody war
whose outcome affects us all
[Music]
I'm headed into quite possibly the most
dangerous place on earth this is one of
the last border crossings into Syria
that's still open
and coming the other way is the latest
in a stream of refugees through a brutal
civil war it started four years ago with
an uprising against President Assad and
what followed was a descent into chaos
now Moscow's intervention and support of
the Assad regime threatens an
international crisis and while Russia
and the West can agree the Islamic state
is their common enemy no one has yet
come up with a plan to stop them
I'm in the back of the compound and for
a reason all the way down to the Syrian
front one I'll put the two lights in the
front both locals both know that they're
both gonna die before they answer the
questions and he wrote Glocks
they fooled me a little bit I'm sure
things go wrong
reason I don't want to be seen in town
now is there's a sense people here they
probably have to get their hands on me
they capture me they take me won't know
what to do what they want to do with me
but worse than that
there's OS sleeper cells in town but
they don't overbeat well I'm traveling
through the ruins of the city of
al-hasakah in northern Syria
the devastation all around me has been
caused by intense street-to-street
fighting between local Kurdish militias
and Islamic state forces the engagement
has lasted nearly four months now
and parts of the city of change hands on
numerous occasions and these are the
soldiers currently on top
they are the Kurdish people's protection
units the YPG they are acknowledged as
the most effective fighters against Tyus
but they're also the sworn enemies of
Turkey the West's main regional ally and
that means the most they can expect for
their efforts is a quick thumbs up
intl road of thus advised a regional
headquarters the local commander fills
me in on what's been happening in the
area both mazels around here somewhere
though this stuff on here that we can
both relate to this map is already out
of date in only a few months
much of the region has changed beyond
recognition how Hasek ax is on the
northern point of what is effectively a
new country it's the so-called Islamic
state a control zone that stretches west
into Syria and east into Iraq and one
that threatens the Kurdish people and
their homeland argue that they and the
West share a common goal in defeating RS
but they're lacking the tools to finish
the job but a quick email
yeah what we need are heavy weapons like
machine guns tanks and mortars no one
seems to be cooperating with us we
actually have to smuggle these weapon
ins ourselves if you are going to fight
a big battle you can't just fight it
with airstrikes it has to be fought on
the ground of tanks torrent open
that help is unlikely in the meantime
this lot on the front line will just
have to make do so I've come to find out
how they're coping I am primarily a
soldier and not a journalist although
now I am slightly bigger than a few
years ago feel it is important if the
story is to be told it is to be told
through somebody who understands other
soldiers I wasn't quite sure how much
was lost in translation because at first
it looked as if I wasn't getting through
but then there was a dig at me that
broke the ice they showed you it will
just bounce off outside I was given the
full 360 it's got all the bits and
pieces including underground bunkers to
deal with incoming mortar fire
this position is known as a Forward
Operating Base or F OB
from here these lads spend all day
monitoring the is frontline and if they
see anything move then it's fair game
thousand liters village free fingers
right a village small building and cops
in the distance driving away from that
and you might not see him now because
he's on a lane is is is the ISIS
motorcycle and he's headed towards that
village in the in the distance they saw
some movement village and because
everything in that village is deemed to
be hostile and then basically nomadic oh
it now they're just they're making a
weapon safe as FATA to is normal
I know from experience that 99% of any
conflict is waiting around for it to go
noisy and I use the lull in the fighting
to have some chit chat and social with
Jan oh let's get away from soldiering
for five minutes because you know you're
a man like myself let's talk tattoos or
tattoos you have I have plenty of
tattoos okay you'll sneak on here this
one here the swallow a lot of people
used to have this in the old days it's a
tighter you'd have if you'd have been
put inside prison so you've been to
prison yeah
he has good man these are these all
homemade tattoos these ones here these
smalls you've done all these yourself
this is this good toy of it how easy he
stumped me with that one okay we'll get
undressed now okay now this is your
girlfriend John oh it was just like me
he liked to get involved and he didn't
have to explain too hard why he was here
these savages are not Aslam and we want
to defend our homes why do they go
around killing innocent people and
children we would not allow them to do
this they're not even human
we have to get rid of them from the face
of the earth one thing was abundantly
clear from the beginning for a bunch of
geezers fighting in the front line
against is or what they called - their
kid was poor - shocking at best this
German rifle wouldn't look out of place
on the Antiques Roadshow tell us where'd
you get this from - from the from dead
body from killed soldier he took this
from someone who was killed yeah so this
is big tough for the enemy this is a new
addition this sight rail I don't think
that the Germans put that on their
original a little bit aside have you
used it have you used it back see did he
get this ask him if he got the scope did
he manage to get the scope from from -
hey
nice that is a serious serious that is
I'm telling it
having said that it all counts it all
counts nobody oh that's all about yeah
form yeah you know so if you're gonna
battle someone huh forget about someone
this bit here what fine yeah so up smash
all right let's pick up get violent with
it yeah good
hopefully you still have some ammunition
I've met some decent blokes in my time
and one thing was for sure
I urge a no and his crew with me rather
than against me any day
[Laughter]
but at last light I began to see just
how vulnerable this position really is
the YPG of top troops and in their
element when it comes to street to
street fighting but this base was part
of an overstretch frontline manned by a
small group with dodgy weapons and if it
kicked off
jano would need to get some backup here
pretty quickly or face the consequences
we're taja easy coming up I'll spend the
night out who the other half of this
formidable fighting force and I find out
what's in store for the is fighters who
go up against them
it's early morning on the front line in
Syria and I plan a visit to some of the
deadliest troops in the war against
Islamic state these are the ypj of Union
fighters of the Kurdish people's
protection units and believe me you
wouldn't want to mess with them
when I first arrived I got the
impression they weren't particularly
pleased to see me
but that was before I'd worked the old
famous cow trick works every time
and soon zoo and showed me one Romanian
hometown she jumped it would help her
she ever got captured by is now was
broken the ice there was one question I
couldn't resist
who is the better fighter the man or the
woman this is my personal opinion I
swear no one has told me to say it women
fight the same as men maybe even better
but now we're all fighting for the same
cause we fight as equals I say that men
can never be superior to women and vice
versa
yes some fight just like men maybe even
better though this is over what how
would you what would be the best thing
that happened I hope this war finishes
as quickly as possible and peace follows
not just here but in the whole world
that's my hope for humankind so that's
the message I sent to the Islamic state
go away this place does not belong to
you this is not a place for lawless
terrorism this is a place for Humanity
all the signs around the base showed me
that this lot have been right in the
thick of the fighting
yet I still found it hard to get used to
the idea of young women on the front
line some just older than my daughter
and then something happened that maybe
look on everything in a new light two of
the fighters Nazrin and zulan led me
away from the camp they said they wanted
to show me where they kept their enemies
[Music]
but it wasn't quite what I'd been
expecting it looked like this was some
sort of trophy room
[Music]
but they didn't stop there turns out
they weren't squeamish about show me
their handiwork
[Music]
for an is fighter to be killed by a
woman is the ultimate disgrace they'll
never make it to paradise
[Music]
that evening another unit of ypj arrived
to relieve some of their comrades a
[Music]
couple of new arrivals were clearly
suspicious for strangers I was later
told that members of this unit had been
badly cut up in the recent fighting the
woman in the white baseball cap didn't
want to speak to me she was one of the
only two survivors of a squad that had
been wiped out in an is ambushed
[Music]
love know what time is with you now and
Nazrin and zealand are often the south
their job is to scout around for is
infiltration units that creeping under
the cover of darkness
no no no I said sell em yeah yep
the first stop is the ruin of a local
prison
this location is of vital strategic
importance and has change hands many
times during the heavy fighting in the
past few weeks the rooftop is the ideal
spot to keep an eye on what is are up to
the position is part of a front line
that runs from the city of al-hasakah
to the town of towel rack in the
Northeast the ypg claim that they
control most of the territory to the
west but this area still suffers
frequent car bomb and suicide attacks a
few miles to the south is a heavy
concentration of by hard is fighters
including foreign mercenaries while over
here in the East is the iose control
zone that now stretches across northern
Iraq
so being stuck in the middle of all that
lot means there's no not enough
a few kilometers to the east we start to
pick up the sounds of a heavy
bombardment
why did John
[Music]
in the darkness account later Australia
but what happens next
confirms one of my worst fears I've just
watch the guys here they've identified a
top you know they've gone to acacia wood
assault district it failed miserably
he's lit himself up in full view of any
enemy sniper frankly if you've been one
of mine
I need it got a good Claire it's a
miracle but no one gets killed
back on the outskirts of the city
Nazrin and zealand's Patrol is coming to
an end
both of them are genuinely guttered they
haven't had a pop with the enemy
I have to say that in all my travels the
ypj are the most extraordinary fighting
unit I've ever come across
but the fort of leaving a group of
poorly armed women on an ill-prepared
frontline left me appalled
[Music]
next up my cross over to Locke and read
the lad living in Yorkshire
it was come back to do his bit I decided
to be part of her fight against to this
terrorist and I roped in to give some
local militia a few tips on stayin alive
you must be kept track I've moved across
the border from Syria and I'm in
northern Iraq it's a war zone but
there's no sign of the Iraqi army a year
ago they were routed by is who help
themselves to billions of dollars of
their American supplied hardware getting
some sort of FOP that courts to see the
places have got pop-up OHP on the net
which is overhead protection so they're
obviously getting some here Russian tank
nearly I've driven into a Forward
Operating Base controlled by the
Peshmerga since the Regular Army did a
runner it's down to this Kurdish militia
to hold the fort
I don't give in Peshmerga are these are
these scars from fighting coming up in
fear by Byung moon shadow papier-mache
contribution got it yeah don't know in
the arm you have a web web what about
this one it was a packet in the Civil
War so you've been you've been through a
lot of action here you need to be
yes I'm sure want me to connect shopping
or do this man here is what the patient
oh there are about a lot of people by
now what it's just giving up the ghost
he's being pretty God knows all that
that's still out here scrapping y'all
got to take my hat off all day to him
the heavily fortified compound is a
strategically vital crossroads
[Music]
it lies at the very heart of a no-man's
land
stretches between Kurdish territory to
the north and the Islamist control zone
to the south
there's not much in the peshmerga locker
to match the modern weaponry lifter from
the Iraqi army and that means they have
to rely on the warmth in the West does
supply air strikes over the past year
the Western coalition has flown
thousands of missions against is and the
numerous kills have had an impact but as
someone who is fought on the ground I
can tell you airpower only does half the
job just witnessed an air strike and
it's fine it's great you know we can
Chuck coordinates down there and you
know we're helping out and everybody's
seem to be doing their bit but how much
is actually been achieved you know -
burger or somebody at some stage score
go down there and get amongst it and
properly sort it out it won't be
achieved by just slinging ordnance out
five minutes later their heads will be
up and they'll be Bunyan waters over
here they'll be firing their machine
guns off that something or somebody has
to properly go into the village and sort
it out and if they don't this is never
gonna finish Islamic state fighters a
rapidly adapted wire strikes
they've withdrawn at the smaller bases
and dispersed their forces over a wider
area and still they have the capability
to launch rapid counter-offensives and
grounder self
for the past 12 months Kurdish
communities across the whole of northern
Iraq have lived in daily fear of Islamic
state fighters only a few kilometers
away one way they prepare for the threat
of an invasion is by banding together
and setting up defensive militias yasser
abdullah emigrated to yorkshire 16 years
ago but this summer he returned to his
own village to protect his people
I seen the TV and the UK look at people
travelling for all all about the world
they come into our country follow the
ISIS going through Syria fighting our
people I decide we say endure you can
doing nothing I couldn't handle
stand stay in the UK to do nothing about
that I decided to be part of a fight
against - this terrorist yes Iran is
mates a cold fire force unit 8 0 and
it's made up entirely of part-time
volunteers presumably a lot of the guys
that you fight alongside tell me a bit
about them with their backgrounds who
are they what do they do they are
everyone they had different life so what
you work with their companies we've got
their own shop some of them working with
the market some of them working
Peshmerga some of them working different
jobs I've got everyone that had
different job and when this star and
everyone left their job and decided to
fight against this Isis
[Music]
only a few hours after I linked up with
the SEO they get to come to the front
line
[Music]
right so there is apparently a sniper
out there
yeah I'm not at any fizzes way yet but
these guys won't be keeping his head
down so so we'll just kick this house
out the chevy army has all been paid for
by ourselves you know having been with a
British Army had all this sort of stuff
laid on for me they get nothing but my
respect for doing this out of their own
pockets but it's not long before a
witness a familiar sight dodgy opiate
that packs up in the heat about leaving
them with nothing but their defiance
where is my your Peshmerga by the year
you know that you have nothing but
respect for me
so things have calmed down a little now
whoever was doing fine early was
probably we've drawn they've certainly
had a fair amount back from these places
we've just seen some of these people are
trying some of them are taxi drivers
bankers whether all right they're out
here giving it stacked against an enemy
that is to be fair quite well organized
quite well equipped and quite motivated
without the fear of dying as well after
the concert
it's back to unit headquarters
over the usual cup of chai I had a
chance to think about what it's just
saying and I was worried about the basic
level of combat awareness yes er in his
manager that's good okay if I'm not
firing my weapon my finger should be
nowhere near the trigger okay if I'm
moving if I'm moving down or up the
muzzle must be kept up I should never
get up from the same place that I go
down in case the enemy's saw me go down
okay come on come on come on if they
just stay here okay sniper goes one two
three boom boom boom boom yeah ma free
muscular Matthew muscular palace all
gone yeah let's go
good these are too good they're getting
it they're good okay these two need to
work together yeah good that's better
in the end it wasn't much of a
contribution hey go back just a couple
of hours in the afternoon running
through the basics burn the light of
everything I was finding out it was the
least I could do well as you can see
I've got a pretty bad stoppage on this
already and that's indicative of what
these soldiers are being issued that
it's absolutely jammed in there a rock
to get it out I'm not you're going to
continue with his test-fire and to be
honest that's a rifle that's been given
to a soldier to fight with over here
okay that would have happened to him in
battle
so the say that these people need kit is
an understatement right already just
looking at this weapon it's got a
plastic handle three different types of
wood it's been cannibalized probably
taken off with two or three different
soldiers about this and possibly even
been killed with it due to stop which is
like that and they're putting that
against weapons of an issue by the
Americans to the Iraqi army and then
subsequently lost and have gone into the
hands of is so the only thing that agent
Stevens is fight up at all is the fact
that these guys are so game and willing
to fight because otherwise I won't be
this we will bar is already
next it always noise and I are unarmed
in one of the worst firefights of my
life
[Music]
this is a Seon camp in northern Iraq
it is now permanent home for more than
15,000 easyly refugees last year the
entire regional population fled from
their homes in the north following an
all-out assault by Islamic state
fighters are you your buddy yeah
the Yazidis have been subjected to a
brutal regime of ethnic cleansing driven
out enslaved and murdered by the
Islamist fanatics for their religious
beliefs
what happened are someone here who were
what's the story blonde well they shot
her in the head here and here
she was foolish thinking she could run
away so they shot her it took my
granddaughter despite my shouting and
screaming and begging
they took her mother and her auntie in
fact they took all our women my
granddaughter was only ten years old
she's never seen her since no no they
brought her back to me twice they
brought her back at night and then took
her away again there was nothing they
did not do to her
come across some fairly hideous things
in my time but that is just appalling
absolutely dreadful I just I don't want
to talk about everybody scream blue
murder at the plight of these CD people
yet nothing has been done that means
that these kids could face an entire
lifetime in a camp like this
ya know a little come on here we go here
we go wash welcome bottoms I love you
I'll let you use both hands both hands
one genuinely genuinely heartbreaking
days you know got kids of my own
they ain't done nothing members of this
some of those have been here a year and
it does two breaks me up
[Music]
I'm on my way to Sinjar now is the heart
of what used to be the ezd homeland
before they were forced out
this is now the front line for some of
the fiercest fighting against is
anywhere in the world
and once again is the peshmerga during
the heavy lifting you tone properly
constructed holes here for returning
fire and the enemy are literally now
anywhere between 200 and 300 meters in
front of me which is well in range
within a couple of hours of our arrival
I witness one of the regular air strikes
and while there's no doubt that the
fighters here welcome all the help they
can get
the reality is is our still dug in and
going nowhere
the battle for Sinjar has been going on
for over a year now and both sides are
bogged down in a stalemate the Peshmerga
commander tells me it's because they
aren't properly equipped to do the job
to be getting this done we need many
things here high quality night-vision
goggles are essential for us we are also
dangerously low on ammunition we need
modern assault weapons so we can attack
enemy positions and vehicles safely from
a distance we are lacking in firepower
because as you can see the weapons we
possess are very basic
I've checked the Scimitar check we've
just been told by one of the guys that
they are expecting an attack and they've
got the intelligence by listening in to
the walkie-talkie which goes straight
back to Isis
as the threat of attack increases the
Peshmerga begin their ritual taunting of
the enemy
[Applause]
[Music]
voices or levers no I just had stuff
coming in from Ohio
[Applause]
[Music]
it was time to move up to the high
ground to get a better view of what was
happening along the whole front the
exchangers went home for another hour or
so before eventually dying out in the
early hours
[Music]
the morning after fighting sees a
gradual return to normality
although there is still always the
possibility of a Dona Sol
[Music]
it's hard to explain to outsiders what
it's like to have been in combat and the
only people who really understand it are
those who've been through it
[Music]
for me the battle here at Sinjar summed
up everything not witnessed this is a
dirty war of attrition against a
ruthless enemy fought on our behalf by
an eloquent irregular force
[Music]
who in my opinion need a bloody sight
more than a pat on the back if this
fight is ever going to end
[Music]
you